les allemands vont devoir vivre avec une
température de 15 degrés à la maison
comment vont-ils faire
le reportage présente ce clip tourné par
un ministère allemand à l'automne 2021
une femme frigorifié doit signifier à la
façon de chauffer son appartement avec
un pot de fleurs et quelques bougies
conclusion l'hiver en allemagne risque
d'être douloureux si le pays se passe de
gaz russe depuis l'annoncé des sanctions
début mars le nombre de milliardaires
russes dans le monde a baissé de 30%
en deux mois les plus grandes fortunes
russes ont perdu plus de 250 milliards
d'euros
en fait il faut s'y risque comme des
sceaux sur les planches l'intervenant
explique on va devoir nettoyer plein
douceur mois le surf n'est pas du tout
mon truc
nettoyez encore moins jeune femme de
ménage décidément à les rendre à a
décidé de me faire sortir de ma zone de
confort tout aussi alarmiste cet autre
reportage d'une chaîne de moscou sur ces
images tournées par une télévision
chinoise
la journaliste s'inquiète à berlin les
gens arrivent tôt il essaie de prendre
le plus de voix possible
tout le monde passe commande parce qu'on
risque être en rupture de stock
et les conséquences du dérèglement
climatique sont chaque jour plus visible
d'ailleurs à partir d'aujourd'hui on vit
à crédit mais ça mérite une explication
là aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on appelle le
jour du dépassement ça veut dire que
nous avons épuisé toutes les ressources
que la planète peut nous donner pour une
année alors à partir d'aujourd'hui la
planète à l'antre en déficit écologique
comme l'a établi l'association de
protection de l'environnement wwf c'est
beaucoup plus tôt que les années
précédentes où cette date tombe est
normalement au mois de juillet la
plupart des éleveurs nomades de cette
région du sud-est de l'ethiopie ont
perdu les quatre cinquièmes de leur
troupeau quelles que soient leurs
détails c'est le désespoir
que dieu nous aide
qui la donnent de la pluie
n'avait vu des chameaux manger d'autres
chameau j'avais jamais vu ça je ne pense
pas que notre mode de vie sont livrés
la girafe est un emblème du kenya
dans le bush elle n'a pas de prédateur
pourtant sa population ne cesse de
décliner elles sont moins de 100 milles
dans toute l'afrique cinq fois moins que
les éléphants elles s'éteignent dans
l'anonymat
[Musique]
c'était le cas jusqu'à récemment
jusqu'à ce que cette photo bouleversent
le monde entier albert camus est
rare c'est ça exactement 1 milliard le
truc à faire parce que c'est
l'anniversaire de mon mari et du coup
j'ai fait venir à la maison notre chef
préféré le joël robuchon c'est pas parce
qu'ils pensent que je vais faire des
pâtés au poulet à la base alors même que
joël robuchon je n'avais pas faim
notamment parce qu'il est mort en 2018
franchement je suis tout sauf parfaite
parce que depuis tout à l'heure il y a
annoncé mathieu
leur film moi jeune fille
qui ne joue pas sur scène avec un
endiablé baisse je pense que je fous là
battez vous mangez
[Rires]
non
c'est bien élevé je te représenter
anissa vous êtes de versailles bon oui
je suis marseille et je voulais vous
poser une question est ce que c'est vous
qui a dans le clip de l'algérino deux
clips
on m'a dit ça m'a fait beaucoup voilà
l'annoncé c'est un sosie de
l'homme de néandertal était découvert
dans la vallée de neander en allemagne
et on a longtemps cru à tort qu'il était
peu intelligent car son crâne et plus
allongé que celui de l'homo sapiens et
il avait proposé aux mots cupide us
quel sport l'américain alan shepard
at-il pratiqués sur la lune
[Musique]
à l'émulation pour enlever la natation
je pense de
saut d'obstacles aussi me paraît pas
très judicieux sur la lune la marche
nordique de la marche par 10 c oncernant